في باريس تعرضت شقت مصمم الازياء العالميه
لصعب لمحاوله سرقه في الدائره السابعه
عشره مساء الجمعه وصلت الشرطه الى المنزل
بعد ان تلقت بلاغ من احد الجيران صعب
تتفاجئ بوجود رجل يراقب الشارع وينتظر
النزول رفاق اللصوص من الشقه
قوه الامن الباب الرئيسي للشقه
بعد غياب المصمم
اللبناني خمسه اشخاص حاول بعضهم المقاومه
قبل الاستسلام للاعتقال يبدو ان هذا
البلاغ جاء في وقت مثالي اذا كانت كانت
هذه العصابه على وشك كسر خزنه مجوهرات
مثبته
الحائط اعطاك السوء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات